I,
um,
I learned that over the weekend,
uh,
of the death of club Levy Strauss,
I don't know if you read it in the paper or if you know who caught Levy Strauss
was GLAAD Levy Strauss who was 101 years old and he died,
was a great French anthropologist.
Uh,
the founder of the school of structuralism,
although he would never admit to do that,
uh,
truly a remarkable intellectual figure of the 20th century,
who travels through the jungles of Brazil and,
uh,
wrote a number of very important,
anthropological books and one a and memoir called Crisco Pika.
Uh,
54 55,
a,
which is a truly a beautiful,
beautiful book.
And I was very moved,
uh,
reading the obituary,
in that he said at one point that he had learned,
uh,
to pursue,
the truth doggedly and also,
uh,
had the idea of reviving something from the past while reading Don Quixote as a
child in a children's,
a addition obviously translated,
uh,
into,
into French.
So,
uh,
I thought that I would mention that,
beginning of the class and also,
uh,
as an homage to a,
to a real,
a really great,
uh,
figure of,
of our day.
Um,
I have been insisting in my last a few lectures on how said Advantis we rights
episodes from part one in part two.
And I want to begin today with some general statements,
statements on this theme and a few other general statements as we approach the
end of the novel.
Uh,
first I want to make clear that not all episodes in part two are modeled after
others.
In part one,
there is no antecedent really for the cave of Montesinos adventure and a,
which is the highlight of part two and perhaps of the whole book,
nor is there really an antecedent for the clubby lane,
your flight.
Uh,
so there are a number of important episodes in part two that are,
uh,
not model on every salts from part one.
You will get to see a sigh announced,
uh,
episodes in to that repeat or rewrite episodes.
We thin part to itself,
which is very interesting.
Second,
I want to emphasize that they rewritings and expansions the rewritings are
expansions of those,
uh,
episodes in part one.
They are like blow ups.
Uh,
one could say of episodes in part one,
they tend to have more characters and the actions are outrageous in comparison
to their predecessors.
For instance,
there is something of the fight with the Basque in donkey holders encounter with
Samsung Carrasco this guys as denied of the mirrors.
But the second episode is richer,
uh,
in the first they're both mounted,
armed and don't.
Quixote wins.
Uh,
the same occurs in the second,
but now his opponent is playing the role of uh,
at night.
He's outfit reflects a donkey hotel literally and metaphorically.
And the whole set up is carefully prepared to resemble a contest between two
nights,
uh,
done.
None of these,
uh,
is,
is present in the,
in the earlier episode.
This expansion or enlargement is consonant,
is consonant with the increasingly baroque aesthetics of part two.
And each instance of a rewriting is like one more proof of it.
Uh,
one more proof of this,
of this baroque,
uh,
aesthetics.
Cervantes has not remained the same.
In the 10 years that have elapsed between parts one and two,
and the old Cervantes,
Eh,
is his own measure of development as it were.
I don't know if I make myself clear.
That is the set of aunties of part one is the measure for his new sense of
development
in the episodes that I will be discussing today and in subsequent lectures,
this process of expansion is itself expanded,
reaching the limits of representation,
uh,
which is again also a characteristic of the uh,
rook.
I also want to insist on something that I have only hinted at in previous
lectures and that you may have noticed on your own the increasing presence of
Virgil and he's an EAD.
As we move towards the end of the second part of the hotel.
Uh,
I will be more specific on about this one.
We get to the meet LTC Dora,
give my hello.
I've already met if you have read far enough into the book who is a parody or
model after died off.
But I just want to mention that because the Virgilian background may suggest
something important about how servant this conceived Don Quixote.
In his second part,
nes is known for his Bruton's for his sense of duty from the very beginning when
he carries in a crisis on his back as they leave a burning Troy.
I'm when he repeatedly fence of temptations died be the most memorable so that
he can fulfill his destiny,
which it will be nothing less than the founding of Rome.
And ies has,
uh,
the greatest excuse for leaving a woman in the whole of Western literature.
I've got to go found wrong.
Um,
Don Quixote cannot aspire to search a grand design,
but said Advantis has given him a different,
no less serious one and one that is a consonant with the age in which he lives,
which is no longer the heroic age of Virgil's characters.
And that design is to conquer himself.
This is going to be Doki this task,
the evolution of the Mac Don Quixote towards sanitary and self knowledge is the
modern equivalent of an ess pollutants and task of founding the great city.
This,
it seems to me is the overall suggestion in this repeated illusions direct and
indirect to virtual.
Before of course,
I spoke of homer of it and Dante and,
and about how Vantis a field of illusions and sources had moved up from the
romances of chivalry to the core of the western tradition without abandoning,
of course,
the romances of children.
I also want to emphasize,
I've already mentioned it,
uh,
that these episodes are rewritings and in this major episodes in part two,
there is a strong presence of death.
One way or another.
Uh,
sometimes as in the pageant in the forest is a very figure of death,
uh,
as an allegorical,
a figure of death,
uh,
that you,
sure,
uh,
remember,
this is very much again and I will be emphasizing today in one of the episodes,
very much a part of the,
of the Baroque.
Before I,
uh,
I moved,
move on to some,
the truly outrageous episodes that I want to discuss today.
Let me say something about Sanchez letter to his wife and about the exchange of
letters that takes place in this section of the novel
said Avantis who anticipated so many things in the novel.
I think I've mentioned before,
they've Garcia Marquez,
the great Colombian writer said that everything that anomalies could possibly
want to do is already insolvent.
But Cervantes in these,
uh,
exchanges of letters is anticipating epistolary fiction.
Um,
the letters to the Ressa between Theresa and the counters and so forth.
Uh,
there are antecedents,
uh,
in Spanish,
for the,
uh,
for the purpose story fiction.
But here said,
run tests in a modern,
uh,
already modern novel is a anticipating that kind of fiction.
The epistolary novel he's wanting,
which the whole novel consists of an exchange of letters,
uh,
between the characters,
as a genre.
It became very popular in the 18th century,
as I'm sure you know,
in the works of authors such as Samuel Richardson with his immensely successful
novels.
Pamela 1740 and Clarissa 1749 in France,
there was the late [inaudible] Santa by Montis cure for,
by Julie Hula Nouvelle a Luis by June.
Jack who saw and lack clo a novel that I'm sure,
uh,
you have ready,
if not seen the movie Lillia Zone,
don't universe,
uh,
in Germany,
good to the sorrows of young Werther and links Hyperion.
So I mean,
uh,
what said Ron,
this is anticipating here,
it was a very popular Jonathan in the next,
uh,
century.
Um,
this exchange of letters in the cohort.
They also reflect a society in which writing has become a crucial component of
life
and,
uh,
communications,
of life and communications,
writing and printed documents,
a rival,
uh,
oral exchanges.
If you have been reading your earlier,
you will have learned that this is a society obsessed,
uh,
with documents,
mostly legal documents,
uh,
which is a class two,
which some of the letters belong.
Letter writing is part of the generation of,
of the,
uh,
production of,
of legal documents.
Uh,
so this is a reflection of that too.
it is also here in the novel.
It is also writing within writing and the epistles are documents not processed
into the fiction,
but presented a raw,
I said where many it is.
It doesn't say that Sr,
uh,
Sandra road would that SSA and this and that and the other?
No,
the document presumably as was dictated by Sandra,
of course,
he doesn't know how to write a appears in the novel,
uh,
modern modern fiction.
We'll expand on this device.
I'm thinking here of Joyce,
of the fossils of corn tasa and other writers,
uh,
whose books are contained documents.
So just these letters,
uh,
own absorbed into the pros of a,
of the fiction
now
Sanchez letter.
If we want to also,
uh,
look for the antecedent in park one,
Eh,
is an echo of the one don Quixote wrote to Lucy [inaudible] and essential of
course for God to take with him and then a memorized.
And we have all those funny episodes in which he tries to,
to,
to retell it,
uh,
as in the first instance that his ass in that episode or those episodes,
the humorous,
uh,
what is humorous here,
he said,
both sanctuary and his wife presumably are illiterate.
So this is an exchange of letters between,
uh,
characters who don't know how to read and write the whole issue of the
production of the letter of the Dutches overseeing it and all of that,
uh,
is part of the of the humor here.
I us,
uh,
the production of the letter for dosing there was also part of the,
of the humor,
uh,
in,
in that episode.
So now we do move to these outrageous episodes that I went to,
uh,
discuss today and uh,
I'm sure when I mentioned what they are,
you will,
you will see why I used that adjective.
Yeah.
The first is the episode involving the afflicted matron,
known as counters three fall D and a three file dean of the white beard,
her squire.
This is one of the wildest inventions of the Duke Stewart and one of the
strangers in their whole Quixote with no possible antecedents.
In part one,
that steward is described as follows.
In page seven or five of your translation by Jarvis is this,
the Duke had a steward of a very pleasant and facetious,
which who represented Marilyn and contrive the whole apparatus of the late
adventure,
compose the verses and made the page act.
Do see now,
I'm now with the Duke and Duchess.
His leave,
he prepared another scene,
one of the pleasantest and strangers contrivance imaginable.
I don't quote,
uh,
their stories and other internal author Luxon Song Carrasco and Master Peter
that sandstone care Roscoe,
he's one who scripts adventures for Don Quixote though.
Something that master Peter doesn't do what must say.
Peter is one of the authors within the Quixote.
So the steward not only organizes the whole pageant but also writes the verses
as we,
as the quote says,
and,
and plays the role of Merlin and then have to refile.
Ding.
He is as versatile as he knows the person won't and even more,
uh,
he's a port
now.
Internal authors like him and Samsung Carrasco,
uh,
in the second part get to put into action their creations as we have a,
as I have mentioned before,
and as you had seen the,
uh,
the results are not exactly what the plant,
but they do get to put them into watch.
Okay.
The staging of,
uh,
his arrival as three file dean is theatrical and Baroque in the extreme.
Again,
the intention is to astonish both with the elaborateness of the props and with
their fearful appearance and sounds or noises.
So the astonish with the,
with the,
uh,
the act of creation.
I mean,
uh,
the creator,
creator of this Baroque,
uh,
pranks,
is boasting of his own,
uh,
ability and also as tarnished because of the very nature,
size and noise.
If we go to page seven or eight,
seven or nine,
uh,
I will read the arrival of this character.
And while there were those in suspense,
they perceive two men entered the garden clad in morning robes so long and
extended that they trail up on the ground.
They came beating two great drums covered also with black by their side came a
five,
the five black and frightful lag.
The rest,
these three were followed by a percentage of gigantic stature,
not clad but mantled about with a robe of the blackest,
the die,
the train.
They're off was of monsters length this row.
But what's good about with a broad black belt or the wish they're hung and the
measurable Symitar in a black Scabbard,
his face was covered with the transparent black veil through which appear the
prodigious long beard us why he does snow.
He marched through the sound of draw of the row of drums with much gravity and
composure.
In short,
his huge book,
he stateliness his blackness and his attendance,
my very well saw price as they did all who'll be held him and we're not in the
secret.
Those he came with the state and appearance or force said a kneel down before
the Duke who with the rest received him standing.
But the Duke would in no wise software him to speak till he rose up.
The monstrous Spector did.
So.
And as soon as he was up on his feet,
he lifted up his veil and exposed to view the Horace list,
the longest,
whitest and best furnished beer that human eyes do then had ever be held on
straight.
He sent forth his broad an ample breasts.
The Var is grave on Sun rose and fixing his eyes on the Duke.
He said,
oh,
of course.
Notice the preponderance of black.
And notice that as in the pageant in the forest,
uh,
these,
there are many superlatives.
Everything is the largest,
the whitest demos,
horrible.
And the intention is to,
to cause,
uh,
admiration and fear on the spectators.
Santo dives into the duchesses skirts.
The moment he sees this apparition.
I see he does whenever he's afraid.
And he said the Duke and Duchess,
his house,
he did.
He think that in her arms,
in the pageant,
in the forest.
I notice also the figure of the monster.
I have spoken about the figure of the monster before we,
we chose done only
made up of the most outrageous features,
both of contrasting one like the black dress and the white beard.
The monster is a baroque figure.
It does not have to be ugly.
Just composed of clashing features in Calderon de la Barca,
the playwright that I have mentioned several times,
uh,
okay.
In colonial America.
Okay.
They're beautiful monsters,
namely beautiful women dressed as men.
So don't confuse and figure of the monster with the romantic,
a Frankenstein who is a ugly,
repulsive,
uh,
and,
sort of a dearth death warmed over type.
But this is not the case with this baroque monsters.
Um,
the,
the important thing in the monster is the clash of opposites.
The clashes between the two genders.
In the case of the Caledonian figures,
uh,
we sold that clash in the figure of the do now a of the pageant in the forest
such figures out the opposite of renaissance harmony,
but they are however announced in the figure of Dorothea in part one.
Uh,
and as in the Cave of Montesinos,
uh,
the pageant in the forest,
we have a procession that parade of freaks and the sound of drums,
which mark the pace of the whole ensemble,
uh,
in this theatrical shows,
the characters don't work.
They march.
Remember in the,
in the cave in Montesinos how all of these,
uh,
he re kind of women are marching in the procession.
And of course in the pattern and the forest,
we have a huge,
uh,
procession parade.
Uh,
so there's no,
no natural motions such as walking.
It is marching to,
uh,
to the,
to the beat of the drums and the sounds of the various instruments.
Now,
the most remarkable thing here of course,
uh,
is the punishment within all of his fiction,
that the Duenas have suffered.
Uh,
the predicament of the millennials is again,
a question of cross dressing or of Cross gendering.
Uh,
there mark afflictions seems to be an excess of testosterone that provokes a
wild growth of facial hair.
Remember that they suddenly within this fiction,
uh,
how these beards,
it is described in my new detail how the,
the hairs I supposed to come out of the pores and
mmm,
this is wild.
This,
the third one,
they said his wildest,
you know,
this is a hilarious condition and part of the mockery of ladies in waiting in
the whole episode,
Sanchez diatribe against them perhaps reflects an attitude of the,
uh,
of the Times doing Rodriguez from whom we will hear more later mounts a spirited
defense.
I'm using both Dwayne and Dwayne.
Yeah.
Uh,
and the Spanish is a
okay.
And,
uh,
what is using your translation
is the English version Glenn.
Okay.
Good old [inaudible].
The Covarrubias remember him,
the great lexicographer who published in 1611 that Tesoro,
the [inaudible] and that I,
uh,
warn you I would mention several times during the semester,
says the following in my own translation.
Defining the dual.
Yeah.
And going through all this,
because I know that this is a very strange figure for someone in the 21st
century.
Uh,
he says in old [inaudible],
the old Castilian languages is good.
Also was done.
It meant an old widowed lady.
Now it generally means those who serve wearing long nonissue gowns to
distinguish them from verges and in the palaces honor.
Yes.
Our principal ladies who are widowed and the queens and princesses keep them
near,
uh,
unquote.
Meanwhile,
Webster defines lady in waiting as a lady of rank who is a member of the royal
household and in attendance,
uh,
of a queen or Princess,
I suppose this is me now,
I suppose there is a sexual connotation to this category of women because they
are unattached,
attached where presumably available.
They're not young,
married and Virginia.
Why so many widows?
I mean the death
people died at a younger age in the 16th and 17th centuries.
So as he's,
men normally live a shorter life than women.
Even today.
Uh,
there are bound to be a lot of widows around.
And what do you do?
What do you do with his widows?
Uh,
where do they go through society?
I guess some might go to a,
the nunnery God got d two,
the nunnery to remember Shakespeare.
Uh,
but others are there in the palaces.
the are of rank.
They're a bit,
a bit like the second don't is that the female counterpart of the [inaudible]
donuts,
but they cannot quite go out and,
and,
and start a career,
uh,
out at sea or the church or low.
So
they,
uh,
they are,
they are involved in,
in providing or facilitating sexual encounters.
There go betweens.
They tend to be go betweens as happens in the story concocted by the Stewart.
Uh,
I think that,
uh,
this is the reason these sexual,
a sideline of these widows,
they all kinds of jokes about widows and sexuality and all of that in throughout
all traditions.
Um,
and this is why they are given ingest a strong masculine trait,
a beard,
the opposite of the role they're supposed to play,
which is very,
very feminine in a sexual way.
So the last thing you would expect them to have a beard,
but also you remember from our,
my explanation of self esteem,
of duty,
nails,
hair that,
uh,
you know,
it,
it meant also certain kinds of sexuality.
Uh,
so hair in the case of the enchanted don't see now meant,
remember the,
the,
the winch that had the mole on her face with some hair,
that Gnocchi holder said she must have another one on her thigh with hair,
it's et cetera.
It means sexual proclivity being sexually hot.
Okay.
Uh,
these women are to be seen as sexually active but only in only in a sexual way.
That is,
they are not to be loved and idealized there only to be seen as sexual.
And this is why the joke of having them grow hair.
Uh,
no.
The story about the counties three fall faulty whom we encountered.
Remember in spitzers article,
remember the long discussion by Spitzer about the three file,
the DOR is filed,
does and all of that.
And how,
uh,
how these names,
are made by Cervantes.
The story about counters refiled is very much like that of Princess Mikami
corner.
Uh,
in part one,
you remember that the total payout except that that it is madly exaggerated.
I mean,
there is a fantastic geography,
outrageously made up names.
It is a Meta Meta fiction concocted by the characters of the main fiction.
But here in contrast to two part one,
uh,
the process is much more premeditated complicated and it's played out as a
senior theater,
not out on the road.
If you remember the priest and Dorothea make up the story of me,
call me Kona,
uh,
on the go.
Uh,
and that's where she makes mistakes.
Remember,
uh,
the Stewart has taken his time to compose.
This one is a whole story.
Very,
very well rotted.
Where
my room Sia and Archie PLR are the disease.
Uh,
uh,
parents my wounds.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
they are funny names.
I mean the first is German town of mines.
Okay.
It sounds very strange to Spanish er,
my rooms yet with wounds to your mind's in Germany.
And uh,
the second refers to watch PLO go a series of islands.
Uh,
the,
these names are geographic in origin because the story has something of a joke,
something that the geographic fable come,
diarrhea is another.
[inaudible] is a made up a kingdom.
But all these names,
the funniest is antonymous.
Yeah.
The young woman,
because it is the name that takes the name of names,
then it is every,
it's a rhetorical figure.
It names [inaudible] the rhetorical figure that,
Eh,
it's a rhetorical figure to them that which is the queen testaments of
something.
Hercules' for a strong man is an Pono Masiya Hitler for an evil man is an
antonymous.
Yeah.
Uh,
from the Greek who called by another name,
they use of an epithet or title instead of the proper name of a person.
As when I'm warding Webster,
when he's owner is used for George,
or when instead of Aristotle,
we say the philosopher,
the use of a proper name instead of a common noun as when an eminent aura is
called the monster.
Ernest on quote
is something like same par excellence,
the quintessence of something.
So Hawaii is,
he called [inaudible].
Uh,
she's given the name of a linguistic or rhetorical term because cheese is made
up of words.
She's a fiction within the fiction made up by the store.
So she stopped to have the name of a real person because she's made up of words.
This is what this is,
uh,
this name is,
is underlining also,
uh,
Geez,
so named because she and her story are a quintessential architype pro common
place
walking past El Dorado,
whom I have mentioned
before several times
cause I'll go to,
it was a very
prominent,
his moon is in the 50 seat.
He,
um,
he was very impressed with German criticism and so he named all of his books
same Thedo you format day sense and meaning of Don Quixote.
Celestina Nola,
same Pladis seen form is derived from German criticism.
But in spite of that,
it was a very good,
uh,
critic and I'm quoting,
from his book called [inaudible] of course.
Uh,
and he says,
uh,
Don Quixote in his purity launches fourth to disenchant to save the lovers and
the Duenas to make them recover their original form.
He fights for the whole of humanity,
which is why the story is filled with a sense of the real without alluding to
any one in particular,
because all are involved.
The name of the Seduce Young Woman is,
I'm Tomasia.
What he means is that antonymous,
she has name suggested Gnocchi.
How the fights for all so deals and punished young ladies,
and this is the sense of of her name,
the Prato typical one,
but also since the issue here is one more time of marriage on equal marriage.
Freedom.
Social status,
I think said lump this,
what's his name is perhaps poking fun at himself for repeating the same story on
the various guises throughout the Chiota.
He's saying,
well,
this one is [inaudible] is the prototypical of all the stories.
Dot.
All Day I Marcel and so forth that I have been telling what I'm telling you
again,
so I'm making fun of myself by giving her these very,
very funny name.
Hey,
my also be casting a resigned on ironic a glance at human nature for always
repeating itself.
Young women will always be seduced by chairman young men.
I'm trouble Willand Zoo.
This is what a name like I'm Tomasia suggests too.
Yeah.
The rhetorical name also reveals that he's proxy,
he's standing offer.
The steward is a learned man.
It is us.
If we called a literary character,
I've been thinking of what other rhetorical name could we give a literary
character?
Anaphora for instance,
Anaphora is the literary,
uh,
is,
is there is the,
uh,
is the,
the figure of speech,
uh,
by which a,
an aura repeats over and again,
something,
uh,
as in the case of,
of the assistant of master Peter's a system.
When he says,
look,
or when the preacher says,
repent you sinners and says it over and over again,
that is an Africa.
Uh,
I don't know if you agree,
you can come up perhaps live in a better one.
Synesthesia,
you could call and they'd already character.
These are also very good names.
Did you have a pet to name?
Uh,
if you have a parent that repeats the same thing over and over,
you could call her anaphora many case.
Just a,
just a thought.
But it's very funny to have a character called Anaphora is supposed to be very
funny.
It's,
it's a,
it's sophisticated joke.
I mean not everywhere and not everybody knows what [inaudible] means,
but uh,
but it is supposed to be a funny and it is.
Now
if in part one we learned to look for the story behind the story.
Okay.
In part two we learned how a story is made and the way that this,
uh,
steward appears and the way that the story is told and is,
presented unrepresented is a way of showing,
uh,
the inner workings of the story.
So this is one way that we can also contrast between the two parts.
In part one,
we're looking for the story behind the story of what [inaudible] said.
Here we are shown the stage props.
The machinery is the station machinery,
uh,
through which the story is being made.
Part of it is the name of his,
of this character.
Now,
so to sum up the story made up by the stored my rules and Archie PLR are the
parents of princess and Tomasia impregnated by don't clubby one type with the
connivance of Dwayne [inaudible].
Now notice our clubby hall is a Phallic name.
Uh
Huh.
Uh,
[inaudible] is a peg.
Ha is a peg,
uh,
in a,
in a string instrument.
Uh,
now,
now they are,
um,
they have a little mechanism with a screw type thing.
Uh,
but the old glovie has the old pegs simply stog stuck in the by pressure into
the ward.
And hence the name.
[inaudible] is a very phallic name.
I know a joke on the part of Cervantes.
[inaudible] is a silly Stena type.
Remember Sestina they go between 1499 who arranges for their encounters,
but she falls in love herself with a young man,
which gives a story,
an original twist,
that kind of sophisticated twist.
This old older woman,
uh,
has fallen in love with [inaudible] who's a very charming guy who plays the
guitar and all of that.
It is a Sushi,
vicariously had the affair with clubby hope through a antonymous.
Yeah,
so there is a,
uh,
there's a clever sophistication involved in the,
in the story here.
Now the stories are very,
uh,
a clever awesome.
Now don't Cubbyhole Dawson,
Mary Antonio Masiya as he had promised,
but the queen dies of grief because of the disparity in social class between
them.
He is merely a night.
He has the dog,
so she uses a night,
but she's a princess.
I'm Tomasi is the princess.
So Milan,
Bruno,
a giant and the on the Queens first cousin.
Who is the panda Philando of this story.
My Bruno.
Okay.
Turns them into the ornament.
A top a sarcophagus.
Now,
uh,
if Banfi panda,
Philando,
remember what the Pan Philanderer,
the one who had many affairs with women Pan Philanderer.
Milan Bruno is a bad man
from model.
Okay.
Evil or bad,
an ombre man
or on Bruno manly.
He's a bad man.
Milan.
Bruno.
It's also comical name.
Uh,
yeah.
In any case,
this is the,
uh,
the gist of the story.
Page seven one nine upon the Queens,
Hawker appeared mounted on a wooden horse.
The giant Marlin Bruno,
her cousin German,
who besides being cruel is an enchanter,
also the giant in revenge for his cousin's death and in chastisement of the
boldness of don't clubby.
Who on the folio of Antonio Masiya left them both in chanted by his art.
Upon the various supports a poker,
he converted into her converter,
into a monk.
You have brass and him into a fearful crocodile,
well,
I don't know,
metal.
And between them lies a plate of metal.
Likewise with letters engraved upon it in the Syriac language would be rendered
into Ken,
Diane,
and now into Castilian contains the sentence.
There's too presumptuous lovers shall not recover their Preston form to the
valorous man.
Checkin shall enter into single combat with me for the destinies.
Reserve.
This unheard of adventure for his grade valor alone.
Quote,
notice the Baroque suffusing of love with death.
The lovers likeness will lie upon the tone of the dead.
Mother don't overlook that the steward author of the story is learn it as well
as clever as we found in the pageant of the forest with all of the Dante
Aleutians.
And in his name of Antonio Masiya here he has contrived a truly baroque image.
In the sarcophagus,
I have given you a,
a,
um,
a handout,
or on the one hand,
I could not,
uh,
resist,
having a,
a,
a door,
a drawing of the Duenas,
uh,
as they,
supposed to appear in this episode.
But on the other,
I have a series of sarcophagi guy because,
uh,
American tombs,
tend to be very simple.
Uh,
there's a headstone and then the tomb is just the grass covering the body of the
casket or something is something very beautiful about it.
Uh,
dust,
we become dust and so forth and so on.
But,
uh,
in the European tradition,
the continental in the,
in the continental tradition,
uh,
tombs tend to be much more elaborate ordinate and,
made of stone or a hard surfaces.
They are like little buildings that is a whole architecture of tombs.
So what is the sarcophagus?
Remember the Etymology I gave you when discussing the cave of Montesinos
episode,
Sarah Course in Greek flesh and Fargo line to eat.
So the sarcophagus eats the flesh of the dead body.
Uh,
sarcophagi were common among the ancient Greeks and Romans.
You have some here.
Uh,
it was a limestone coffin or tomb,
often inscribed and elaborately ornament.
The point of the sarcophagus in this story is the display and the ornamentation,
which are the baroque elements as in the figure of the monster.
Remember the,
that in Montesinos cave ornament on Buddha Undark this sarcophagus was his own
cadaver.
The statue is made of flesh.
It was an inversion inversion with nature play.
The role of art.
Here we have a much more elaborate kind of ornamentation.
How do we interpret the figures of the Monkey on the crocodile here?
Okay.
There are monkeys in Cervantes as we saw with [inaudible].
Uh,
and also,
Eh,
the monkey that matter,
Peter had with him,
I guess I said in when mentioning those episodes,
they allude to me Macy's to representation because they like to imitate humans
here.
Uh,
the ensemble could allude to,
to lost the CROC eats the monkey as it were.
Uh,
but both animals are,
uh,
the monkey on the crocodile are supposed to be demonic and symbols of
dissimulation of fakery.
This is why they grades the tomb of his lovers.
Now the story of antonymous yeah,
and don't clubby who is one of conservation and pregnancy.
I think that the pregnancy is part of the Baroque grotesquerie of the episode is
the interested intervention of the UN year of the,
uh,
what I mean by that is that there is something grotesque about the go between,
the older woman falling in love with a young man and at the same kind of
grotesqueness,
uh,
is involved in the pregnancy.
This contrasts,
uh,
you will find in the poetry for instance,
of Ltc Laura when she appears and sings a song.
There will be so blind lines followed by very vulgar ones.
And this is the,
I think the effect here of the,
uh,
of the pregnancy pregnancy would be unthinkable in the stories of part one
involving Doterra,
Marcella,
Lucinda or Soraida,
although consummation did take place with Dorothea.
But pregnancy literalized lost,
uh,
removing idealizations about love.
You don't underscore it.
Underscores loves functional biological drive to reproduction.
Uh,
pregnancy is not very sublime.
It's not part of the,
of the,
of the courtly love tradition.
It is,
uh,
unthinkable who imagine Beatrice Dante's below it,
pregnant or any of these ladies.
Uh,
so there,
there will be a,
another pregnancy later involving [inaudible] his daughter.
And we will discuss the episode,
uh,
at this stage in the Quixote.
We are well beyond the idealized love of [inaudible] one Marcella or don Quixote
and don't see nay.
Let's see.
Naiah has been enchanted,
took,
sorry,
like,
uh,
a country wench.
So,
uh,
now we come to the end of this adventure,
the end of this very well rod story that the steward has composed and whose
inner workings we are,
uh,
observing as we read,
we moved out to the episode of Clary Lania Globulin.
You became such a,
or has become such an,
uh,
an ingrained name in the Spanish tradition that there was a very famous literary
journal in the 30s in Spain called [inaudible].
Now,
uh,
this story brings to a close the story of the beer they're doing.
Yes.
And the disenchantment of Antonio Masiya and Clerico.
Now first,
the chapter begins with a mock derived of self praise on the part of Savantas
about his narrative techniques and characters.
Page seven,
2021 in reality and truth,
all who delight in such histories as this ought to be thankful to its original
authors.
Sit Helmet for his curious exactness in recording them.
I notice circumstances,
they're off.
We thought omitting anything,
how trifling soever but bringing everything distinctly to light.
He paints thoughts.
Discover is imaginations,
answers the salad,
clears up,
doubts,
resolves arguments.
And lastly manifests the least atoms of the inquisitive desire.
Oh,
most celebrated author or happy Don Quixote.
famous Lucy.
Now office issues central Panza live each jointly and severally infinite ages
for the general pressure and pastime of the living.
Now this is very funny.
It's Atlantis bracing himself.
Uh,
and he is praising himself,
uh,
by anatomizing as it were,
the,
the props of his own fiction or of his own,
uh,
the makeup of his own art.
Uh,
what's the rant this is doing is this missing Aristotelian injunctions
concerning the writing of history in this passage?
According to left philosopher to use an internal Masiya to refer to,
uh,
Aristotle.
History should not concern itself with minutia,
but only with that which is relevant to the ground narratives which concerns
itself with major historical figures,
not with characters of the ILC servant.
This is dealing with nor should history dwell on their thoughts except when
expressed in highly rhetorical speeches that are presumed to express and display
their personalities.
Now,
this is so against our modern conceptions of history,
uh,
that,
[inaudible] this already aware of it because we,
we,
we do want details about the characters in the important and not important
characters in history because we,
we feel that in the details,
uh,
you may find the truth.
No,
not in this renaissance conceptional of history.
This is the what,
uh,
what I have just,
giving you is the core of the renaissance poet,
uh,
of history.
Uh,
but in this mock history that Cervantes is writing,
uh,
it is precisely the particular details as well as the thoughts and imaginings of
the characters that are of interest.
The most.
The remoteness,
uh,
element of these renaissance poetics of history is the question of the speeches.
Because of course,
there were no recording devices at the time.
So when you hear a king,
uh,
deliver,
an aeration,
uh,
it is all made up by the historian whose art,
involve the creation of such,
uh,
speeches on the part of this historical characters that would reveal their
personality.
It was a way of,
of,
of delving into their psychology.
Now I know this is completely against our notions of how to write history,
but this is why savant this is underlining it here.
Uh,
he is interested in the details and he's interested in the imaginings and the
thoughts of characters who are not that important,
but are the characters who will pull people that novel that he is,
uh,
creating.
So,
in other words,
this tiered shows that said,
manthis is increasingly aware that is creating a new kind of writing,
which is derived from both history and jaw Hos oh,
the new,
such as,
uh,
the epic,
the picaresque and the Romances of children that you ride by the way out to be
presumed to be ordered by the second author or translator who frequently
comments on Cedar Math work the story,
remember,
uh,
who's,
a more,
uh,
given to prevarications.
So we have all of this falls on layers of irony is still oppressive,
but this is important because of what I said before,
a stories in,
in,
in part to displaying the how they are made up.
So we moved to Kerrville.
And your first,
the name of the Horse,
it is derived from Glover.
Okay.
Which means a nail,
but the results are an echo of glovie.
Ha.
The word that I used before that I mentioned before in reference to [inaudible]
because the clubby high itself is derived from cloud,
meaning something that stuck.
Um,
and this alludes to the steering,
uh,
peg or what I mean,
a pilot would call the yoke of these,
uh,
through a steer.
This,
uh,
this horse,
um,
and Lania.
Okay,
Len,
you know,
which mean w means ward,
which is what the horse is made of.
But linear or linea is it kind of would use for fire wood for burning.
The more noble would use by carpenters to make furniture or cabinets is called
Marvetta.
Of course.
[inaudible] is to own wheel the word,
uh,
and also Cervantes is on the lining that this board of which,
Globulin you is made.
It's not of the noblest would,
uh,
there's something demeaning to lay new glovie lane used to name God.
[inaudible] I think I,
I kept thinking what would be a good translation into English or what a
rendering through.
I thought that,
uh,
the horse could be called firewood or he called me call.
I think that the best would be woody.
I think that if we were to really translate everything in the book,
uh,
clubby,
then you would be called woody.
I think woody woodpecker.
Uh,
but Jarvis Jarvis wisely sticks too.
Clubby later doesn't translate that.
But that's,
that's what the sense of it is.
Now.
The adventure of curvilinear is derived from several or similar ones in romances
of chivalry.
So the parody of Romances of chivalry is carried out now,
not so much by Don Quixote and his actions.
What by the Duke servants,
particularly the Stewart.
He's not only learn it and clever as I have been emphasizing,
but he's also a reader of romances of jewelry out of course of the first part of
the Quixote as well.
The motif of the flying horse has a long tradition,
including Pegasus in Greek mythology,
but the figure traveled long in time and space after the Indian and Persian
versions.
Three appears in the Arabic story,
the Ebony Horse in the thousand and one nights from there,
it was disseminated through France and Spain.
Uh,
I won't give you the names of the titles of some of these romances in which it
appears,
but it's a figure that appears fairly frequently.
So obviously this reveals the stores,
uh,
knowledge of these romances of a,
of jewelry.
Now,
what is one of the interesting features of the flight is the all encompassing
view from above that the characters have presumably have,
which is typical of the Baroque,
the baroque effort at all,
inclusiveness,
which is now available with the knowledge that the earth is round and complete
within itself.
The episode has a great deal to do with contemporary discoveries about the
infinite dimensions of the cosmos of which have spoken before and the inability
of Ptolemaic and Aristotelian cosmologies to represent such a,
such a cosmos.
Don Quixote on Sandra believe to be going through the spheres as described in
the old cosmology.
And this is the,
of course,
they encourage this by having this,
a fire next to their beards or they're facing.
So they figured they're going through the sphere of fire.
Yeah.
Uh,
and central claims that he took a stroll among the constellations as they're
described in this old cosmology.
The corollary of,
uh,
the new discoveries is that the world is one on the same everywhere.
Uh,
Sandra had introduced the topic a few pages before when upon hearing the story
of [inaudible] and [inaudible] income,
diarrhea,
he says,
page seven,
one eight.
What are their court,
our whistles,
ports and rumblings in income Dahlia two hour if saw,
I swear,
I think the world is the same everywhere.
Santo is,
uh,
thinks that the world is the same everywhere.
And this is what,
uh,
the view from above,
suggests glad we Lanio flight in the Kihatha is the gorilla the opposite of
course,
of the cave Montesinos descent down.
Oh No.
Appropriately giving his increasing importance.
It is now Santo who tells a story like the one donkey hope,
the toll after emerging from the cave,
he speaks of a celestial flight down,
uh,
drawn from similar flights of the spirit,
that are available in Cicero,
some UMES Scipione as in boy,
atheists,
the consolation of philosophy and even in Louis [inaudible] still [inaudible]
Lewis delay.
Oh miss another great port of a 16th century that is somewhere in the background
here.
Um,
I seen other episodes in the second part.
Don't be hope.
The shows real courage.
Before,
before what appears to be actual danger.
So those central,
uh,
but they have played again the role of objects of the others,
amusement.
So [inaudible] episode is another prank.
I know that a bullseye is the word that I keep using Moodle,
a prank
at the expense of Don Quixote on central conceived and executed
by the Duke's minions,
particularly the steward.
All of these pranks are a critique of me Macy's in that they are literary or
theatrical acts of representation which are presented as pitiable attempts
ultimately given up in favor of humor.
These are attempts or literary representation that we Macy's and they wound up
being funny.
These I think encapsulates Cervantes,
his own effort in the Quixote.
They are dramatizations of his plight and answer to the problem trying to
represent reality and they're coming up with a funny version of it.
Uh,
but there is something else to perhaps even more important in this practice and
in the club he linear one in particular,
while it is true than Don Quixote on central are made fun of and that they
endure hardship and danger when the whole contraption blows up.
It is today who show courage and determination and it is day who do fly in their
imaginations while the pranksters remained earthbound,
some like the Duke and duchess astonished and even frightened by the machinery
that they have constructed or had constructed.
I think these some sub,
it seems to miss Advantis his attitude towards the protagonist.
He may very well be ridiculous in his efforts,
but he's Halfords have a certain no blueness that others luck.
Justice he emerges on from the explosion and fall gives dignity also remains on
touched in brief.
[inaudible] does afford Doki hotter a flight I'd once heroic and inspired us in
the episode of the Lions.
I repeat.
He has demonstrated his courage even if the context is not a heroic corn.